for me first time doing a real series
lead title character superhero there
wasn't a lot not to like
the day Oliver Queen died is the day
something new was born I didn't think
that there was any chance that I was
gonna get the part because I thought
that my Canadian agent jinxed it you
know what I mean I was I had been
sitting with my cousin at a hockey game
and he had said have you have you read
the script for arrow said nope
and he said normally when I read a pilot
script I picture me this timer of the
pilot script and I pictured you so you
should probably get an appointment for
that appointment came through two days
later and five minutes after that my
Canadian agent sent an email to
everybody and he's like Steven this is
the one that you've got to get this is
awesome and I went well great it's gone
now forever it wasn't until I read the
pilot and I had a picture of it in my
head and I pictured it the way that I
wanted it to be and then I asked the
creative team what their vision was for
it and the two things just synced up
perfectly so at that point and then you
know you you book your screen test
you're going and you're starting to test
for it and then you just want it for me
first time doing a real series lead
title character superhero there wasn't a
lot not to like
[Music]
I am arrow it would be great for me if
the audience respected the Oliver Queen
character they don't necessarily have to
like him as long as they respect his
methods if they think that he's not
virtuous then that's a problem but for
me it was more I totally trusted David
Nutter who directed our pilot and you
know he he's putting as much of his
reputation on the line as as I am
actually I think probably more so and he
constantly made a point of saying to me
you and me were in this together and the
first day that we were coming to set for
hair and makeup tests sort of like the
first day of school for everybody all
the departments are there I'd been up
there for a couple of weeks but it was
arriving at the studio and seeing what
seemed like 700 cars and thinking oh all
of these people are here for a show
called arrow in a pilot in which I'm in
97 percent of the scenes and if I do a
bad job we're not gonna get picked up
that lasted for about five minutes and
then I was okay
the island forged me into a weapon then
I will use it against the criminal and
the corrupt I loved playing sports
growing up I was super competitive and
almost to a fault and I hadn't really
played organized sports since high
school so I remember coming into this
opportunity and thinking about it like
well here's my chance again to have a
reason to really really push myself you
know I I stayed and I stayed in shape
before but it wasn't it wasn't like this
and and we're still toying with the idea
of what the ideal physical shape for for
this is I mean there was one thing for
the pilot which was I was probably a
little bit bigger and bulkier than I am
now because I was so I was cognizant to
the fact that I didn't have a great deal
of size and so I put it on quickly and
then for now it's more okay let's make
the body as functional as possible and
focusing on the core and I'm learning
how to kick which is developing the legs
and hips and glutes and it sucks but it
it's uh it's really fun it's fun because
once once you sort of get on the path
where you know you've gone through the
initial soreness and the initial the
initial I can't believe I have parts of
my body that hurt that I didn't even
know I could have sensation in once you
get past that and you get on a run way
towards you know really pushing yourself
that's when things get fun absolutely
nothing can happen on the show that
can't happen in real life we even know
we've had we had a discussion on the
second episode where there was some
discussion of having me having me fire
and arrow basically hold the bow in
Reverse and then pull out like this so
that the arrow fires this way and and
and fight choreographer stunt
coordinator me bhaktah the idea because
that doesn't make sense would never do
that so we're creating all this stuff
that like you said that you can do in
real life
and as we've gotten onto the show the
pilot they treated me with kid gloves a
little bit because it's just the pilot
I'm in every scene and if I sprained my
ankle we are you know what Creek for
this we have less time to shoot it we
have less opportunity to set up these
big shots so what we're getting is we're
getting more of sort of a guerilla feel
we have a bunch of scenes in the second
episode where they're these big fight
scenes and it's just a Steadicam
circling around and in that case it's
all me and I mean it's fun like where
we're taking stuff and and we're really
applying it and it's it's really cool to
see on camera like you know that a fight
is gonna come out well when you can just
watch a cut of it at the monitors before
sound is in there before they put the
cut in before they color correct it and
you're like that's awesome so I'm really
excited for episode 2
a lot prior to this with green arrow I
had note I had no exposure
I was always DC oriented growing up
which was random but we'll pretend that
what it wasn't now I read Superman and
Lobo and I read Green Lantern a little
bit and then spawn which wasn't Marvel
or it was Marvel or DC Comics but the
pilot was pretty much all encompassing
and they gave me a stack of Green Arrow
books to read it didn't until after the
pilot and then after the pilot I read
everything and you know to have Mike
Grell who I loved his books a lot to
have him illustrate the little comic
that we gave out at the convention I
mean that was pretty awesome and now I
have a new appreciation you know we went
I went to a panel of Comic Con and
watched Jim Lee sketch Batman I mean
this is pretty awesome so I'm getting
more into the books now it's easy with
the iPad too one of the things that we
didn't get to touch on that much in the
pilot was my relationship with Diggle my
bodyguard there was a scene from act 5
that had to be cut which I totally
understand which we basically pick up in
the second episode and I knew that we
would that relationship is critical
because Oliver has post-traumatic stress
disorder which we haven't he must I mean
we see what he sees in the pilot and
there's no way that he's there's no way
that he's not affected by that the
island broke him down to nothing before
it built him back up to what he was so
there's no way that he's not affected by
that so we're going to see how he deals
with post-traumatic stress disorder and
Diggle served in Afghanistan so that
relationship is really dynamic there is
a parade of DC villains coming just
based on episode 2 and episode 3 we have
China white for the second episode we
have Deadshot for the third episode and
I wouldn't expect that parade stop and
then it and then you know it's it's it's
easy to come back into Starling city and
hug everybody hello when you've been
gone for five years but then it's the
matter of okay that initial
it's good to see you has worn off how is
he gonna reintegrate himself back into
Starling city and into his family and
his friends and his ex-girlfriends and
and of course we have Colin and Katie
and Willa and a very distinct lineage
for all of their characters so is that
gonna happen
when's it gonna happen
[Music]